en silencio y con carteles de sus
desaparecidos así caminaban los
familiares de 43 jóvenes estudiantes de
ayotzinapa de quienes no se sabe su
paradero desde septiembre de 2014 siete
años después del caso las familias han
recalcado la falta de avances en la
investigación a pesar de que en su
mayoría reconocen el compromiso de la
nueva administración de andrés manuel
lópez obrador como muestra de su
cometido el gobierno mexicano pidió la
extradición desde israel de toma cerón
quien dirigió la investigación durante
el mandato de enrique peña nieto y al
que se le acusa de haber ocultado
pruebas e incluso el presidente de la
república ha enviado una carta que
pronto dará a conocer el cual se
confirme que ha sido recibida por el
primer ministro de israel
solicitando su apoyo y colaboración el
testimonio de cerón a quien también se
le señala de tortura es una de las
muchas piezas que faltan para
reconstruir el rompecabezas del caso de
ayotzinapa entre los que está esclarecer
la responsabilidad del ejército la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
apuntó a que su presencia en la noche de
los hechos posiblemente fue mayor de lo
estimado anteriormente
vemos que hay algunos avances en la
investigación pero también a los ojos de
los padres pues no se ha establecido con
claridad el paradero de los de los
jóvenes de los estudiantes y hay muchos
obstáculos que están presentando algunas
instituciones como la fiscalía general
la secretaria de la defensa nacional
algunas de las cifras del avance de la
investigación son desalentadoras de las
casi 90 órdenes de captura se han
llevado a cabo menos de 50 y sólo se han
identificado en los restos de tres de
los 43 desaparecidos